from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Subway and India and the US this
is food Wars
Subway sandwiches in India come in two
sizes
six inches
12 inches Subway in the US also has
those two sizes six inch and 12 inch now
the website also says there's a four
inch sub called a Chota sub Chota
meaning small but mysteriously it is
unavailable we called four Outlets
wasn't there and now we shall measure
the 12 inch sub to see if it actually is
12 inches okay when I'm honest right
that's 12 inches all right Subway I'm
getting more than 12 inches here Subway
has given me a 13 inch sub
this is why I love Subway fun doesn't
stop there because in the U.S Subway
also offers catering options first you
can get this a platter which is five
foot long Subs cut into threes making a
total of 15 pieces let's see boom boom
the discrepancies continue here in India
the website says that we too have a
platter option but we called a bunch of
stores no platter option
and on top of that in the US you can get
a three foot long party sub gosh
we didn't get it this time Graphics can
go ahead and put a three foot party sub
right in front of me
thanks guys
okay is my ex-girlfriend running the
subway India website because it's a set
of Lies they not only advertise a three
foot sub but a six foot Giant sub and
surprise surprise we called a couple of
stores no six foot giant sub in fact
they said there are barely any six foot
humans here in India why would there be
a six foot sub and I was like yeah sorry
I am the idiot hang up okay I am a short
thing
175 centimeters
this is how much I measure
now this is a six foot sub next to me
why would this be a thing it's taller
than me
well
Joe is six feet tall so
so if Graphics go ahead and make me a
sandwich in three two one
you know this is pretty comfortable can
we do the rest of the shoot like this
ugh this is pretty nice here in India
Subway has actually opted out of using a
lot of plastic which is why they only
stock these 330 ml cans which I am going
to measure just to make sure we are not
being fooled by PepsiCo
smells like my teeth decaying
yeah looks about right 330 ml
so when the us we're still totally using
plastic cups small medium large and the
large is supposed to be 40 ounces why
someone would want to drink 40 ounces of
something that's not Malt Liquor in one
sitting is beyond me but if you want 40
ounces of soda good Lord Subway has you
covered I of course am curious to see if
there actually is 40 ounces in this
drink full food Wars transparency I did
have to fill up my own fountain drink
let's be honest could we agree that if
you had to get your own drink fill it up
to go you would probably get this much
now keep in mind the cap is recessed
everyone roast me in the comments and
not filling up enough like you can only
fill this thing up so much
oh my God not even close you know I'm
even gonna like get the condensation and
the cup in there just it even like help
tip the scales in their favor right 34.
six you guys are
just say it's the 34 ounce cup 35 ounces
we're still gonna get it
still gonna get it shame on you I saw
that John Oliver episode terrible Subway
shame on you before you do the
franchisees and what you're doing
skimping on the sodas
foreign
menu items from India that you won't
find in the US here's all the Subway
menu items from the US you won't find in
India obviously Subway lets you
customize your sandwiches so we're not
talking about every single different
combination we're just going on what is
on the menu now let's begin it's
glorious the speed is like a Subway
buffet and I get to pick whatever I want
first of all the Aloo Patty this is
basically potato which has been cut up
into pieces and then fried with bread
crumbs on top
hmm
this is not bad but I think you can add
all the fancy sauces you want into this
thing nothing will beat a humble Mumbai
what up corn and peas that looks like a
lot of mayo I don't think I shall ever
order this sub this is a local Legend
This is the first thing a vegetarian
will order at an Indian restaurant
because it's this delicious mishmash of
spices vegetables and potato fried
Tangy delicious next up we have a
Mexican Patty I would like to extend an
apology to all my Mexican Brethren
watching that their great culture has
been reduced to a Patty of Aloo and
beans paneer Tikka beautiful pieces of
cottage cheese as you call it is it uh
weird for me to bite a Subway right
through the middle
would that upset you
[Music]
it's nice I wouldn't go with this
particular combination of vegetables and
sauces also I just want to point out
there are literally three pieces of
paneer in here when I used to go to
Subway in college I would make sure that
they put in like a lot of protein
this is Despicable veg Chic Kebab sheet
Kebab typically is minced meat that's
sort of pressed onto your skewer and
then grilled but this is a veg version
it has a lot of different mixed
vegetables and potato
hmm that's pretty yummy I love the
onions the sauce combination is great
and the sheet Kebab it says not a flavor
next up we have the vegetarian shami
Kebab uh as you can see they're nice
round little balls shami kebabs are from
Lucknow here in India they have a very
crispy exterior and a delicious melt in
your mouth interior they typically mince
meat but this is a vegetarian version
let me try this
hmm
oh
best one so far I'm so full next up
chakpata Chana Subway what a fun name
chatpata means full of Masala zingy
flavor really delicious chanya is
lentils it looks kind of like a dirty
diaper but I assure you this is gonna be
absolutely delicious
oh yeah
that's pretty good now on to the
non-vegetarian sub starting with this
one the Indian chicken tikka it's pretty
good
I just took a mouthful and there was
absolutely no chicken every bite should
have a bit of everything chicken kofta
kofta is basically meatballs and this is
chicken flavored you can see the
meatballs right there
well that's actually really good whoever
picked the sauces on this one this is
the way barbecue sweet onion bit of
ranch a bit of mint Mayo this is the
best sub out of all of them I actually
think it's the combination of sauces
that makes the sub what it is it's
leaking flavor Peri Peri chicken ever
since McDonald's released Peri Peri
fries here in India there has been a
Peri-Peri Revolution over here but a
peri per evolution
as I like to call it a lot of chicken
lot of meat um not a lot of veggies what
happened here some olives would have
nice and finally this rejected Subway
over here is tandoori tofu which I
refuse to eat on principle because we
also have paneer over here it looks
pretty much the same and I'm sure it
tastes great you know what I realized
Subways opened up like this don't really
look all that great on camera do they oh
my God this looks like somebody's organs
U.S exclusive sandwiches you know they
say greatness is in the agency of others
well I'm here to say greatness is an
agency of other sandwiches I've tried
almost none of these starting over down
here we have something called the Maza
meat let's take a look at this Yule oh I
don't think I've ever seen this before
look they even got like the little like
uh
like the fresh mozzarella that's what
looks to be all the Italian Meats oh by
the way unless otherwise important to
the sandwich I got everything with
lettuce tomato and onion and like no
sauce unless it includes the sauce so
some mercy on the people had to wake up
two hours early to make these sandwiches
it's just like yeah just put the same
junk on all of them moving on Supreme
Meats oh yeah this is a Miley salami the
other salami and no turkey though huh
this is Cap ago what is this provolone
cheese this is something that I would
probably get at Subway the Baja turkey
avocado let me open enough for you here
turkey oh yeah hey they were generous
with the avocado I think right going
right in the middle
foreign
moving on honey mustard rotisserie style
chicken
oh yeah
I like the flavor of that better than
like the regular chicken the
All-American Club ham turkey bacon
the Baja chicken and bacon
it's like weak
even the bacon is a lot of flavor
let's get into the steak Baja stick and
jack cheese Black Forest ham
buffalo chicken
oh yeah look at that well they were
generous with the buffalo sauce chicken
bacon ranch
what does it say with like the strongest
flavor and this is the tomatoes you guys
don't have the cold cut combo
that looks like baloney
then we have this next one
the meatball right
India
I assure you this tastes way better than
it looks roast beef is you guessed it
roast oh God I turned red pink is that
normal oh spicy Italian a favorite of
mine to salaam is both spicy you know
just like in Italy
a turkey calorie fresh I'm I think when
something's a Cali sandwich the Cali
means bacon and avocado the steak Cali
fresh
which has one I guess bacon and uh
avocado no ah there's the bacon
[Music]
so unless I got covered in the past five
minutes the food at Subway has seemingly
become incredibly Bland steak and cheese
these steak sandwiches are like bricks
I'm look at this oh yes
now there are some sandwiches which
appear on both menus but have little
differences when it comes to ingredients
for instance our Subway Club comes with
turkey ham and bacon an Italian BMT has
ham
in India a Subway club actually has
turkey lamb and chicken slices and our
BMT does not contain bacon this is
because most fast food Outlets here
don't serve ham or beef because it will
hurt the religious Sentiments of Hindus
and Muslims in addition to our sandwich
fillings we also have some differences
in our bread options we have honey oat
multigrain we have roasted garlic and
Parmesan oregano Italian white bread but
this looks oddly similar to the American
Italian cheese and herbs is it the same
thing Joe let me know no
here's exclusive U.S bread options at
Subway cheddar jalapeno bread
gluten-free bread tomato basil wrap and
Herobrine in both the US and India you
can get any sandwich as a wrap or in a
salad bowl other U.S exclusive option is
the Melt I wasn't going to get every
single melt the list goes as follows
Baja chicken and bacon melt chicken and
bacon ranch melt Baja Steak and Jack
melt buffalo chicken melt ham and cheese
melt Italian BMT melt meatball marinara
melt oven roasted turkey melts spiced
Italian melt steak and cheese melt and
tuna melt I went ahead and got two steak
melts and
oh brother the tuna melts
that looks like cat food
[Music]
I definitely don't have coven because I
tasted that I need a steak and cheese
melt a palette cleanser after that
now we're talking here are our breakfast
sandwich options we have egg and cheese
chicken slice egg and cheese and Western
egg and cheese I am very curious to know
what makes this Western
hmm
I can see how this would be a western
option nice Bland
easy on the palette let me tell you
something about India all right if you
flavor something that we're buying at a
restaurant with just salt and pepper we
call that a rip-off at least at least 10
spices for some in conceivable reason
you can get third breakfast sandwiches
for long flap rods
oh God this and they're so greasy uh egg
and cheese oh look how terrible this
looks oh no where's the cheese and what
oh come on man
[Music]
absolutely not
this really is a bummer
oh my God
did you hear that like I mean these eggs
are you kidding me with this what
I couldn't imagine eating a whole one of
these for breakfast without going
directly back to bed
there's a black Force ham egg and cheese
[Music]
and now let's let's speak of those
breakfasts ever again we have some
exclusive Subway toppings here in the
U.S you cannot get in India such as
spinach banana peppers and Monterey
cheddar cheese according to the Subway's
website in certain parts of the country
you can also get avocado carrot
guacamole sweet peppers feta cheese
pepper jack cheese provolone cheese
swiss cheese here in India unfortunately
all the toppings we have are also
available in the U.S damn it Subway are
we not special enough guys let's have we
know in the comments what special
toppings we should have here in India
however we do have our own exclusive
sauces sauce
starting with mint Mayo which is
absolutely a banger and the entire world
needs to taste this Tandoori Mayo which
we end up using because we overuse the
mint Mayo this balances it out
and finally red chili sauce I've also
never heard of mint mayonnaise and that
sounds incredible actually so in the US
we have a few of our own exclusive
sauces such as Ranch oil Subway
vinaigrette and plain mustard you guys
have honey mustard like us but not plain
mustard and in certain locations around
the country you can also get Buffalo
sauce creamy Italian sauce golden
Italian sauce Savory Caesar sriracha and
uh-oh
Tzatziki cucumber Tzatziki or this is
the tea salad
cucumber in my defense I am incredibly
nauseous what if we took all of the Us
exclusive items and put them in one
sandwich well this time we're not going
to and thank you we actually made an
effort to make an edible U.S only
sandwich what we have is a steak sub
cheddar jalapeno bread with spinach
banana peppers mind reject cheese ranch
and mustard
this all works well together except the
mustard stands out which is kind of a
could do without it and the spinach is
fine don't taste the spinach so I guess
I wouldn't kill me to get some green in
here now what about an india-only sub
here is one with roast garlic bread
tandoori chicken tikka mint Mayo
Tandoori mayo and red chili sauce
mmm I'm really feeling the lack of
exclusive toppings here Subway this is
just meat dipping in sauce make India
exclusive toppings happen right now
Subway this is the Eat Pray Love version
of a sub in the sense that it makes
sense to everybody else in the world
except Indians moving away from Subs our
snack section will tell you that we have
a pepperoni toasty and a veggie toasty
unfortunately at the time that we
ordered it was not available I have
tasted them before though and the
pepperoni one is pretty yummy Subway has
potato chips of course and these are
some U.S exclusives starting on this and
Sun Chips cheddar Harvest Sun Chips and
Subway I've always had a really good
alliance good for them
my favorite Miss Vicky's the jalapeno
chips these things are so good you can
also get the Miss Vicky's lime and
cracked pepper chips the one I went to
didn't have them this I can't believe
you guys don't have the nacho cheese
Doritos I mean this is like
like the most popular chip right and
last Lay's baked and also kids can get a
pouch of applesauce I'm assuming adults
can get it too but they're technically
for kids in India Subways chip options
are a lot more limited and they vary
from store to store the one we visited
had a variety of flavors in coronitos
which are basically nacho chips and lays
and they had my personal favorite lace
flavor West Indies hot and chili but the
crew has informed me that they will not
roll further if I don't give a shout out
to India's magic masala
our Subway cookies have one exclusive
flavor and that is this the raspberry
cheesecake
this is so good I don't know how they do
it we saw to have an exclusive here in
India in the US you can get a chocolate
chip cookie but here you can get
dark chocolate chunk cookie or if you
really want to join the Dark Side a
double dark chocolate cookie
here at the subway in the U.S Coca-Cola
rules everything around me we got a lot
of Coke products here I put these in
order of which one I would probably want
to have with a sandwich coke diet coke
not a big diet guy but it's like with
the calories next is Sprite I mean who
doesn't love Sprite it's a little strong
I don't know if it goes well as a
sandwich but why not then we move on to
the simply drinks you got yourself
simply lemonade it doesn't like lemonade
right Simply Orange Juice I feel like
this is more for the breakfast
sandwiches right I mean OJ after 11AM
seems kind of strange to me and then
there's apple juice if you want to have
an energy drink with your
sandwich Vitamin Water triple x
and Gator Gatorade yeah I mean I like
Gatorade but I mean it doesn't pair with
food at all last and not least all
natural energy green tea hydrated
coconut water antioxidants electrolytes
with ribose let's find out
whoa that's terrible this one smells
like BL
ah here in India Subway is actually
partnered with PepsiCo so instead of
Coca-Cola products you can get things
like Pepsi Mountain Dew Pepsi black
mirinda Tropicana orange juice and Aquos
water from the makers of Aquafina that's
so complicated why it's like a movie
title at this point
which country is getting a better deal
on its Subs let's compare a foot long
turkey sub in both in the U.S this will
cost you
8.99 in India ordering a foot long
turkey club sandwich on zomato one of
our food delivery apps will cost you
476.19 rupees that's around 6.27 right
now and while that's 30 cheaper than the
US sub it's still pretty expensive for
the average Indian for context in under
seven dollars you can feed an entire
family of four and you're gonna get a
very delicious hearty meal in most
restaurants over here now to play
Devil's Advocate the Subway near my
college back in the day had a crazy deal
going on where they gave us a six inch
sub a cookie and a drink of our choice
in under two dollars and we used to eat
lunch there nearly every single day so I
guess from store to store there are
different offers and Subway is and can
be kind of affordable Subway prices have
been a contentious issue in America for
a long time a franchisee named Stuart
Frankel invented the five dollar footlog
back in 2003 which hit the mainstream in
2008. cheaper labor and food costs
combined with an increase in foot
traffic meant the promotion was actually
a huge earner for Subway sadly it didn't
last and a deal was phased out around
2012. when Subway tried to bring it back
in 2017 it was met with uproar from many
franchisees who said it was impossible
to make a profit from the promotion the
same thing happened again in 2020 when
Subway tried to push a 10 for two
footlongs deal which was killed after
two weeks
which country Subway is the most
unhealthy let's start with a footlong
turkey sub at whole grain bread with
lettuce tomato onion peppers and
cucumbers in the U.S this sandwich
contains 520 calories six grams of total
fat 2 grams of saturated fat 78 grams of
carbs of which 12 are sugars and 1580
milligrams of sodium in India the
nutritional information for this same
sandwich is 586 calories 6 grams of
total fat 4 grams of saturated fat 94
grams of carbs of which 8 grams of
sugars and 1 362 milligrams of sodium
when you break food down like this it
sounds pretty scary
so the U.S sandwich has more sugar and
more sodium than the Indian version they
have the same total fat content I don't
know what to take from that but the
Indian version has more calories
saturated fats and carbohydrates than
the US version my theory is because we
have that extra inch what's the most
calorific thing in the U.S menu
currently it's a foot long Cali fresh
steak sub with smashed avocado on whole
Italian bread one of these is a hefty
1220 calories there's also it's 68 grams
of fat in there 87 of your daily
allowance as well as 2 380 milligrams of
sodium over 100 of your daily allowance
the most calorific thing on the Indian
Subway menu is this paneer Tikka sub
footlong whole wheat bread with standard
salad it's a whopping 820 calories now
this is less calorific than the American
Cali steak sub and contains
significantly less fat at just 41
percent of your recommended daily intake
the main thing to wash out for however
is a saturated fat there's 16 grams of
it in here which is 80 of your
recommended daily intake oh saturated
fats you slide dog
I didn't know that would happen but
there you go Subway